cool ask a question so if you were
somebody who was very attractive not
academic at school like struggled with
school and maybe didn't have very much
support around you whether that's family
or friends and you saw that as a way to
like yeah alleviate your life into just
getting money quickly why don't you
marry rich
it's not that easy compared to uploading
the video You're an eight nine or ten
girl yeah those girls if they go 20
years older what the hell they have
they'll have so many guys lined up today
even if I could marry a 50 year old even
if you haven't wrinkly penis do it yeah
do you want money you're talking about
do I want to be on the internet naked
forever which one if I was that
desperate I would pick I would pick but
at least you feel like you have a
barrier like keyboard Warriors you would
feel potentially protected by the
internet because you're away from them
they don't have access to you protected
at what course yeah because most women
who who go through this like the the
um mental health is through the roof
like most people that do it most people
that are important do not want to be
important I think that the average
um death rate for women in porn is that
horses it's like 36. so they're not
living happy lives that far again fast
money slow problems do you know what I
feel like I feel like in 2022 you
there's there's women that
um yes don't want to be in the industry
of corn and only fans but there's
actually women that want to be doing
this is that they actually enjoy their
job oh they do they're addicted to
attention and yeah but I'm saying not
everyone's coming from even fact of like
you know has no family or what have you
like these are some people who have come
from established homes and it's
something they enjoy doing well they are
because they don't want to work they'd
rather they'd rather take the easy way
out than get a job like men do or like
anyone else's I think as well though a
lot of jobs nowadays they're seeing the
pair comparison to say like an engineer
the same work in a month and only fans
and they're saying why am I studying for
a degree where I could literally just
get shirtless in a second and selfish
like
I guess but then at the point it's
literally like is self-respect more than
six figures at this point it's like what
is self-respect at that point do you
know why it is yeah because you have to
think like everybody's thinking short
term yeah in a long time yeah if you
look at our athletes for example most
athletes after retire most of them will
retire around 30. I think it's 80 of
them go broke you're talking about
you're talking about these only fans
people who make a fast amount of money
without building the mentality of how to
manage that money you're gonna lose that
money so then you're effectively in a
worser place than you started so then at
least you have yourself respect you've
got a base or a foundation to start from
if you go into only fans put yourself
out there lose your social capital and
your respect and then you're broke as
well you're just the biggest loser in
society and and it's Legacy one day
you're gonna be 70. like we're gonna
live to be 90 most of us
what's the second half of your life
gonna look like probably alone if you
did only fans 100 yeah okay that's um
that's very shocking okay okay let me
ask them
and um would you wife a girl that does
only fans don't even there's no point
even ask you that question that's a joke
okay okay yes or no no wife a girl that
does only fans not for me no wife a girl
that does not wife girls babes
I didn't think it was very um
it's wife a girl that does only fans no
oh well would you have to guide us only
fans
just because of my standards though but
I'm trying to play Devil's Advocate just
to keep yeah but honestly like for me I
want it at least me like very intimate
and I for me it loses its intimacy if
everyone else has seen everything else
that is my prized possession not my that
sounds really weird but like do you know
what I mean like it's your human
companion so like if I know my human
companions just everything is everywhere
it loses intimacy because like you think
like I'm not naked in front of you like
but I've been naked in front of my man
like do you know what I mean if I think
it just loses that for me yeah just for
me personally but obviously other people
have different stuff like a lot of
people in our age now have open
relationships because they don't need
that intimacy but for me I like knowing
like the only person who's seen my man's
clothes off is me and vice versa but
other people don't really care it's
literally just people standing there is
a song for the more valuable but
valuable it becomes so if the thing is
given out to everybody again it holds no
value if you want something yeah yeah
it's like most people buy brand new
phones you don't go to the shop to buy a
secondhand phone you want something
brand new what I'm saying
well I think
I mean I understand where everyone's
coming from but um the the fact of the
matter is the option is there for them
you know we live in this we live in a
dead age where
um there's there's plenty of opportunity
to make money whether or not it's the
right choice or not that comes down to
um what you believe in and so on and so
forth but what I don't like to downplay
anyone's hustle because it's been done
yeah so people look at me and think oh
you're a professional football okay but
that's easy you just kick a ball around
they're saying no more when it's not
it's actually a lot a lot that goes into
it so whether whether I'll not agree
with
um being on only fans and being a sex
worker called this and the other but I
still feel like they are working for it
and if there's a market for it so I have
a question how many years did you train
to be a professional footballer
[Laughter]
that was a great question
um
I mean I started my dad started training
me at the age of six and most of your
life and then yeah and then I got
scouted at 12 and then
um 16 until so most of my life I've been
looking at it yeah how many years how
many years did bad Barb bad what is a
bad baby bad baby train to do only fans
and make a million she's doing only fun
yeah
18th birthday she's made like 32 million
yeah she made a million on the first
night yeah
so question how many years did she train
for that
it might have been a hidden school
[Laughter]
if that was a hidden skill that she was
training for yeah yeah but
um no that's a fair point she probably
didn't have to train for it but the fact
of the matter is
um she saw the opportunity to make a
million in a day and she took it now the
repercussions of it like he was saying
people most people don't think about
that because you live in a society where
it was so uh was so prone to him well
we're so drawn to make him false money
well they think the money will keep
coming and that's what and that's what
we're seeing now with this because
um like this is from Yahoo finance um
the UK economy shrinks in April as
household struggle against the cost of
like of living
um in the U.S U.S weekly jobless claims
or um housing hits 13 month low Biden
wait another one Biden under pressure as
U.S inflation and it's 8.6 percent the
highest in 40 years so there's recession
coming yeah and and that's why everyone
I think wants quick money just like
it's it's going up but like the job's
like an engineer a nurse this and that
aren't going up so people are saying
like why am I studying three years for
something that I can't really this girl
is making 86 000 a year that's what is
she doing a nursing yeah a girl it's a
nurse she quit yeah yeah
but that's that's still good money in
the U.S 86 000. our nurses don't get
that here
right but what I'm saying is it's people
with high paying skilled jobs that are
leaving that to do only fans yeah and
the problem is long term like what does
this do to them well the thing is if the
high school if you would have got high
school already and you go only fans when
their session comes I went back some
high school jokes he's gonna hire you
how are you gonna know why are you
they're gonna do it
did you say how are you going to no
everywhere how are you going to fight
you're on the internet there's there's
gonna be yeah but my hand will differ to
my real name and why are you almost why
subscribing to my channel well that's on
you but this no no no but this is what
you don't understand like companies are
gonna find ways to track faces that's
going to be a new Industries finding
people [ __ ] online because they don't
want to hire people that are a liability
if we hire you and you're like front
facing towards customers your liability
yeah my parents like fair enough I mean
why do doesn't require me to be searched
like that so I've never thought yeah I
didn't think that was the point my
handles my handles are very different to
my name on paper so yeah you know so so
yeah are you talking about do you have
an only fans no why are you smiling at
home okay but if you did like and then
you said you wanted to go into a regular
job it like everyone at your work could
not know but it takes two seconds for a
customer to walk in Black I swear I'll
subscribe to you and then they tell
someone else and it becomes viral
a teacher got found out that way it's
kids in the primary school Foundation
yeah yeah that's what I saw but I think
one thing that's important to mention as
well is that I'm not I don't think we're
seeing here that only fans is a bad job
or this time over what is telling people
to understand the repercussions of your
actions because a lot of people are too
fixated on the now if you don't focus on
the future that's where you fall into
silly mistakes what and I don't think
the government should have to pay for
you later if you're making six figures
in a month and now you're out of money
because you made poor choices like why
do I have to pay for that like why is
that my problem now and that's what's
gonna happen with a lot of these girls
is they're not going to get married
because who's going to want to marry you
after only fans and then on top of that
they're going to end up on the streets
because they spend all their money
because most people that get money quick
it goes quick is there a way to do only
funds without showing your face yeah of
course yeah
so does that is that the same thing then
you still have to promote everyone you
won't make enough money if you're not
sharing face trust me
hey
that's a marketing genius you need to
show your face you want to draw I mean a
thousand people watching it no like I
said I have hobbies that I like to do in
my spare time but yeah but no if you
don't show your face you'll make enough
money you need to show your face to make
more money and if you're a pretty girl
you want to show your face
see even that that says a lot the fact
that you have to show your face to make
the most money it it it it it just
proves the point that they
um I don't know the founders of only
fans or whatever they know how much is
at risk so that's why they're paying you
more so what's your no no they're not
paying your subscribers
only fans was built as a platform for
artists artists to actually give behind
the scenes to their fans yeah and then
what happened was they didn't
put a cap on like adulterated content
and then
yeah people's lives it could go away
tomorrow I mean they talked about last
year they talked about getting ready
yeah and so you don't know how long
it'll be yeah
what because they just aren't getting
the only fans or the whole like just the
only fans
talked about this um rest in peace but
like when when he was still alive he
talked about
um how okay I can't remember how he
phrased it but basically it's going to
be tough for them to get investors to
take it to the next level and if they
ever want to do that they might have to
get rid of the x-rated content yeah and
so then overnight all of those girls
could be poof out of the job yeah and
then what is that is that influences
though it's that same thing influences
on those kind of people oh is that we
want to attack we want to attack like
you know sex workers on only fans only
fans Not Just sex with mentioned that
it's not just that but then if you're
influencer or your podcaster your
YouTuber like that tomorrow could go
away and then you have no some people
have no skill and they're doing these
they're doing these jobs like all these
passions or whatever and let's say
tomorrow you have less than subscribers
who how do you think what but there's
there's a difference though because
certain so I put it like with with my
podcast right it does I'll always have a
job because I know how to run all the
equipment I know how to run multiple
camera like there's skills I've had to
take to get here there's some
influencers that come and go just like
that yeah but but it's about building
skill sales that'll last you a lifetime
but the the issue that a lot of these
girls are going to have is as quick as
the money came it's gonna go it's just
the scary part and there's no skill if
they have no skill to go with it it's a
bubble I know I know you are arguing no
no I I agree with the free bubble but
I'm just saying that there's a lot of
other in especially now now there's a
lot of other jobs which require no skill
and get loads of money but it's just
like we always
need to attack the only fan skills maybe
because if sex is easier to go for them
but I do feel like there's so much other
jobs as well in this in this right now
in this 2022 where If Tomorrow Comes a
lot of people are broke and not gonna
have you know it's especially women
because women own two-thirds of Consumer
Debt even though we make ten thousand
dollars less than men as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible